direct sur place katia technique bonsoir
katia est ce qu'il y as du manche sur
place
sans stéphanie vais écouter le
rassemblement va se disperser mais il ya
toujours énormément de monde sur la
place l'inconnu était la fréquentation
est ce que vraiment les gens allaient se
déplacer et bien oui il ya eu énormément
des milliers de personnes pour honorer
la mémoire de georges feuilles
d'aujourd'hui pour cet appel lancé par
sos racisme alors évidemment outre les
citoyens de nombreuses associations
antiracistes étaient présents des partis
politiques comme le parti communiste et
puis de nombreux élus 1 le sénateur
socialiste assouline par exemple mais il
y avait de très très nombreuses écharpe
dans cette assemblée très solennelle ça
a débuté par une co prise de parole
ensuite deschamps et puis huit minutes
46 de silence avec un genou à terre pour
la plupart des personnes qui étaient
rassemblés ici huit minutes 46 vous le
savez un c'est la durée pendant laquelle
georges floyd a été maintenu au sol le
cou compressés par le genou de derek
chauvin des longues minutes pendant
lesquelles il a supplié qu'on le laisse
respirer donc je peux vous dire qu'en
effet c'est 8 min 46 et est longue mais
en tout cas une grande solennité
aujourd'hui dans cette pièce de la
république une gestion font clairement
le lien entre la situation aux états
unis et ce qui se passe en france
voilà
oui alors en effet c'est sûr qu'on ne
pouvait pas s'y tromper en lisant les
très nombreuses pancartes 1 il y avait
de très nombreuses connotation des
allusions à la violence policière en
france avec les nom d'adama les noms de
cédric joue via et un appel au calme à
l'arrêt des violences et l'arrêt du
racisme également en france alors je
vous propose d'écouter certaines
personnes certains certaines personnes
rassemblées ici et qui nous ont répondu
à nos questions
si on a tenu à organiser cet hommage
avec autant de jeunes aujourd'hui à 18
heures place de la république c'est
parce qu'en même temps à 11h à houston
était organisé les obsèques de georges
floyd noir mort parce que noir par un
représentant de l'état par un policier
aux états unis même si ça s'est passé
aux états unis
ça a cristallisé une émotion et une
colère particulière en france puisque
nous jeunes en france nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas hors sujet de ce
phénomène qu'est le racisme dans la
police c'était normal d'être là contre
ce racisme contre 7 ses façons de faire
autoritaire de la police ça fait un clin
d'oeil à ce qui se passe aussi en france
même si les choses sont pas les mêmes
néanmoins moi je suis élue de
seine-saint-denis on peut pas dire que
tout se passe dans le meilleur des
mondes
la police est une la sécurité est un
droit essentiel
ça touche les plus faibles la police se
doit être exemplaire et quand on est
exemplaire
on peut pas être le visage de chance et
beaucoup plus médiatisée qu'avant mais
du coup y arriver
dehiba rapport à la situation d'il entre
guînes est toujours existé et elle assez
prépondérante et aux états unis mais
aussi air en france à l'égard des
minorités de manière générale je pense
qu'il ya un mouvement historique qui est
en train de s'établir pour la première
fois dans toute l'humanité voire de tous
les pays on se rend compte enfants qu'
il n'y a plus de place à la
discrimination quelle qu'elle soit ou
place alors à l'antisémitisme plus de
place au racisme tout le monde se
mobilise et s'élève d'un seul d'un seul
homme pour dire non pour dire que voilà
on a connu une période très dure au
niveau de la pandémie qui n'est pas
terminée et que l'humanité a pris le
dessus sur j'espère le capitalisme et
que c'est plus possible actuellement
tenerife dénigrer le mans vous voyez
l'ambiance était certes très solennelle
mais aussi à la combativité
en tout cas là sur cette place le
rassemblement se disperse lentement et
d'entêtement et dans le plus grand calme
car les organisateurs ont bien tenu à
insister il faut garder comme ils ont
dit notre dignité et notre pacifisme
merci katia technique